il y a pas longtemps je t'ai dit que si
tu bois tous les jours et que tu veux
arrêter il faut pas faire ça tout seul
parce que c'est dangereux le syndrome de
sevrage d'alcool pour les gens qui sont
addict pour les gens qui boivent tous
les jours c'est tellement vénère que ça
peut carrément te tuer ça peut provoquer
des grosses poussées de fièvre une
déshydratation sévère qui peut aller
jusqu'à bloquer tes reins Ton cœur peut
s'emballer et cetera et cetera quand tu
bois de l'alcool régulièrement ça endort
ton système nerveux y compris ton
cerveau et si tuarrêtes brutalement bah
à l'inverse tout ça ça va devenir hyper
excitable et ça ça peut causer plein de
problèmes neurologiques comme des
tremblements des hallucinations des
convulsions et ça peut même aller
jusqu'à causer des handicaps mentaux
irréversible il y a plein de trucs à
faire pour éviter ça boire plein d'eau
pour éviter la déshydratation prendre
des médicaments pour éviter les
complications neurologiqu les
convulsions et cetera il faut le
commencer avant d'arrêter l'alcool
surveiller régulièrement pour être sûr
que tout se passe bien donc ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas arrêter de boire si
tu bois tous les jours au contraire même
ça veut dire qu'il faut le faire
justement mais en se faisant suivre par
un médecin